une réunion publique pour présenter son
équipe
grégory pape de la liste nouvel élan à
guyancourt soutenu par lrm investi la
ville à jean monnet ce mercredi 8
janvier
au programme échanges et prise de parole
au total une vingtaine de colistiers
s'est présenté hradiste années diverses
hétérogènes le nist avec des personnes
qui sont neuf en politique
toutefois nous avons des personnes qui
sont déjà expérimentés qui sont déjà au
sein du conseil municipal ou qui l'ont
été pour nous accompagner
mais nous souhaitons une liste avec de
l'énergie sur cette liste on retrouve
notamment jean-luc ev cyr l'ancien
président de la faculté versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de 2012 à 2016
ou encore jean-luc arias conseiller
municipal dans la ville lui ne sera pas
sur la liste mais affiche son soutien
robert cadalbert président socialiste de
saint quentin en yvelines de 1998 à 2000
14 étaient présents dans la salle
grégory pape est tout à fait dans cette
logique dans ces jolis profonde de faire
en sorte qu'il faut être ouvert et
ouvert sur les projets c'est pas pour ça
que si on travaille les gens vous gauche
et droite qu'on s'assoit sur ses
principes mais ce qui est le plus
important c'est la dynamique sur les
projets sur le l'ensemble du territoire
la prochaine réunion publique de grégory
pape sont organisées fin février dans la
ville aux élections municipales sera
opposé à rodolphe baril de la liste
ensemble agissons pour but en cours
olivier paréja de décidons sont pourvus
en cours au maire sortant françois
morton et ahmed ben bella à des qte de
l'union des démocrates musulmans
français